thank you for the introduction today's
topic is going to be a performance
comparison of the Brooker MBT sexy typer
for culture independent identification
and direct anti-microbial susceptibility
testing from positive blood cultures
my name is Lindsay singer and I want to
thank my collaborators who worked
alongside me for this project my main
advisor is Dr Pandey and Ken Oliveira
from Brooker and just a big thank you to
them for making all of this possible
so I want to talk about a little bit of
a background on bloodstream infections
so BSIS affect approximately 1.7 million
adults in the United States each year
and they contribute to more than 250 000
deaths
various studies estimate that sepsis is
present in 30 to 50 percent of
hospitalizations that culminate in death
and unfortunately BSI is the most
expensive condition to treat with a
total of about 15 billion or 4.3 percent
of all costs
this is why it's important to emphasize
the significance of antimicrobial
therapy so effective And Timely
antimicrobial therapy is crucial for
patient survival of bloodstream
infections
for each hour of delay during the
subsequent six hours the chances of
survival decreases by 7.6 percent
and these graphs just illustrate
you know what I have mentioned so far so
the time from onset of symptoms or
hypotension onsense as that goes on your
percent fraction of survival ultimately
decreases
so let's talk about a blood culture
workflow so there's three main
components that take place for a blood
culture first you have your
pre-analytical portion which is timing
of the patient what are their symptoms
do they need a blood culture
then blood is drawn and it gets
transported to the lab ultimately it
gets seated and usually in incubation
type of instrumentation at my hospital
we use the back tech system and when it
flags as positive it gets a Gram stain
leading to culture for organism ID and
susceptibility testing and the
post-analytical portion is notification
to The Physician and primary team
reporting all results and ultimately
consultation and determining how we're
going to treat the patient
blood culture guidelines were
established by the clsi m47 document and
it contains all the procedures necessary
to follow a blood culture
so this is basically what I had
mentioned but I just want to focus a
little bit on the analytical section
here you have a suspicion of sepsis you
then you get the blood bottle collection
followed by incubation
then you have a positive blood culture
alert and this is where I want to you
know key in my focus here we want to see
you know how long and you know how fast
we can get our results to our patients
meaning I mean to the doctors taking
care of our patients so at this point
you know there are many rapid methods
that have been established and I'll
discuss more of this on my next slide we
have PCR methods Etc that are working to
give rapid identification but not
everything is you know
as you know efficient as a full blood
culture result
so let's focus on the next slide here
so word on some rapid methods they allow
identification directly from a positive
blood culture some examples include a
PCR based approach such as the film or
ibcid you also have microarray base
approaches and you know ultimately
there's many limitations you have
species coverage can be insufficient and
most will provide information regarding
organism identification and drug
resistant markers to initiate treatment
which is still very important but a full
blood culture workup will still require
about 48 hours
so I want to focus my attention towards
the broker MBT sexy typer kit
it is a maldivesepsi typer kit that is
qualitative and vitro diagnostic device
intended for use in conjunction with
other clinical and laboratory findings
to Aid and ID and differentiation of
bacterial and fungal infections from
positive blood cultures
it's used with the maldi biotyper ca
system and consists of the sepsi typer
kit and the sepsi type for software
which is an FDA approved reference
library for organism identification
this kit is super important because it
allows identification of microorganisms
within 15 to 20 minutes with Hands-On
time of about 10 minutes making it a
very fast and easy process to Aid in the
care of patients with sepsis and provide
you know results to physician in a
timely manner
so a little bit how this works it's
using the maldi system which is a mass
spec 8 based instrument and it re
results in log score values that are
ultimately used to determine if we can
release an organism identification or
not so broker has established at a score
of 1.8 and higher is considered a high
confidence score and if you know you get
an ID within this range it is acceptable
to be released to the physician
uh 1.6 to 1.79 is in the low confidence
range you might want to repeat the test
or do their extraction method and less
than 1.6 will ultimately lead in no
organism identification possible
so there's been a lot of you know use of
this sexy typeer kit there was a metal
analysis of 21 different studies that
have investigated in the performance of
this kit I want to mention it's only
used for mono microbial blood cultures
so any polymicrobial you know blood
culture sets you know you can't use on
this
for use with this kit but um based on
other studies we've had about 90 percent
of total gram-negative bacteria being
identified 76 out of 2005 gram-positive
bacteria were identified and about 66 of
a total of 188 positive yeasts were
identified
so people are having you know some
pretty successful results with the
broker kit
and generally the sepsi typer performs
better with gram-negative compared to
gram-positive than yeast
so I want to now focus on how I did a
sepsi typer evaluation at Westchester
Medical Center
so let's look at the left here you have
a positive blood culture that gets
flagged in the laboratory at Westchester
if this is from a new patient we will
perform a PCR based molecular assay for
timely identification this takes about
two hours
with that the blood bottle is also set
up to get the full blood culture this
means a Gram stain result an inoculation
of culture media media to be read at two
incubation periods
once we have some growth we're able to
idea using the maldi system and we do
sensitivity using the Beckman Coulter
microscan at the top it shows the
timeline which takes about 48 hours for
a full sensitivity results to be
reported to the position but how long
would it take if we were to use the
sepsi typer kit for ID and then even
maybe take it a step further to see how
soon we can get direct antimicrobial
susceptibility results all from the
sepsi typer
um
hip
so I'm going to list my objectives here
we're going to compare the accuracy of
the MBT sepsi typer kit for bacterial
identification directly from a positive
blood culture to the standard of care
I want to determine if the bacterial
pellet generated from the sepsi typeer
kit can be used to determine antibiotic
susceptibilities for gram-negative
bacteria
and determine the time to final blood
culture results using the septic kit
versus the standard of care methods
so during this study 130 blood cultures
were used that were collected at
Westchester Medical Center
I processed the blood cultures in a
batch system and they were all done
within 24 hours of the bottle flagging
positive
bacterial extraction was performed as
the Perla Brooker sepsi typeer protocol
and the ID was made by the maldi
biotyper system
I then set up antimicrobial
susceptibility for 50 blood cultures
with gram-negative bacteria using the
remnant bacterial pellet
directly onto the microscan
instrumentation
I compared these results for essential
and categorical agreement
and the time from positive blood culture
Gram stain results to final blood
culture report was calculated for 20
cultures
so this diagram illustrates you know how
the sepsi typeer kit is used I won't get
into too much detail but basically you
have a positive blood bottle and you
pour a portion of it into a tube and
license buffer gets added following by a
washing step and ultimately you get a
bacterial pellet that's generated at the
bottom of the tube then you're able to
spot this onto a multitask Target just
like you would for a direct Colony usage
from a plate and run it using the sepsi
typer software on the maldi
it's recommended that you use two spots
one with formic acid and one with L and
if you are unable to get an ID or a
score that is not high enough you can
perform their standard protocol which is
a full extraction method which I have
used myself and it was successful as
well
so a little bit about the performance I
ran 130 bottles on this kit and 95 of
them yielded an ID of any score
I had 92 bottles that had a score
greater than 2.0 and the reason I
mentioned this value is because at
Westchester they only release
a score if it has a log score of greater
than two but that's not really necessary
in terms of the sepsi type of protocol
um jumping down there were 14 bottles
that were in that low range and only
seven out of the 130 failed to give an
ID and though the names of those
isolates are listed to the right I had
three gram positive organisms and four
gram negative two or which were
anaerobes
so I wanted to see if I got a low score
value was the identification still
accurate and as you can see here the 14
are listed to the right and there was a
hundred percent agreement for the
species level ID between the two methods
the stepsi typer and the ID from the
standard of care
so like I mentioned I did 50 gram
negatives
um for an AST comparison so in order to
be chosen to be run for the AST I had to
have a
you know identification on the maldi
that was a gram-negative organism and
there had to have been enough pellet
generated at the bottom of the tube to
be used in this step
dilution tubes were inoculated using
that bacterial palette and this is all
using the microscan and M45 panels
um all based on their manufacture
recommended protocol to the right shows
a little bit about the setup here for
those that are not familiar the
microscan involves you know dilution
trays so you have to inoculate a prompt
bottle and then pour this in and
inoculate a tray which gets incubated in
the machine
um 21 antibiotics were assessed in this
study
for the comparison I use the clsi m52
document
and I went through and I wanted to see
if I would match you know the acceptance
criteria for both essential and
categorical agreement so I'll just
Define these for those who are not
familiar here so in order to be an
essential agreement the percent of
isolates producing my mics must be
within one doubling dilution of the
standard method so that's one portion
that needs to you know
be met in order to be you know
acceptable by clsi the next portion is
your categorical categorical agreement
and that's all based on interpretation
so it's based on the percent of isolates
producing the same category of results
such as susceptible intermediate or
resistant and basing it can or comparing
it to the standard method so this breaks
down further into three types of Errors
you have your minor major and very
major errors so the minor is the least
detrimental effect on the therapeutic
decision it's been when run you know one
form of the test gives you an
intermediate result and the other is
sensitive or resistant
your major error is when you're getting
a resistant result on the test method in
this case the sepsi type are in
conjunction with micro scan versus
sensitive by a reference method
um this isn't the worst but it can be a
serious consequence if therapeutic
options are limited your very major
error is the most serious it's when
you're saying an antibiotic can be
utilized or it's sensitive to a drug and
it actually is resistance by the
reference method so in that case the
method failed to detect the resistance
and it can result in ineffective
therapeutic agent for treatment of
infection
so I won't go into too much detail here
but these were the calculations that I
use it's all in the clsi documentation
and this is how I produce the results on
the next page
so this this graph here shows or this
table shows my direct direct
antimicrobial susceptibility performance
on the left you see the 21 antibiotics
that were used in this study and the top
shows the different categories
that clsi establishes so the First
Column here shows your total eligible
isolates which means how many of the
organisms that are run you know had a
result for the antibiotic listed so for
an example amication at the top had 49
eligible isolates you know
for that drug
now we go further to the right and you
have your essential agreement so how
this graph works is you know there were
49 eligible and all 49 fell into
essential agreement
and the next one would be your
categorical agreement and here we had
all 49 of them matching in categorical
agreements so there were no errors
um but to give an example of one that
did not have everything you know within
a hundred percent match let's see
cefazolin it had let me see
43 that were eligible for the study and
42 of them were in category categorical
agreement which means that we would have
one type of error and if you look down
to the right that would be your very
major error and there was one isolate
that gave a very major error
um I know off the top of my head that
this one was an E coli
um so like I said we really want to
avoid these very major errors
um you know maybe if this were to be
implemented we would have to you know
suppress this antibiotic for E coli if
it was being released
um at the bottom shows the averages for
each category here and to the right
shows the acceptable rates by clsi and
everything you know matched the
expectations in order to be you know
used
for direct AST
so let's talk about the impact of the
MBT sepsi typer on time so I wanted to
see if we were to use this kit and you
know use it alongside the micro scan
system you know how much time are we
saving
so I looked at 20 blood cultures because
they best represented the data they were
set up you know in a time most similar
to when it flagged positive
so what I did is I used the Gram stain
as the base time so I looked at what
time was the Gram stain released by The
technologist and what time was the
sensitivity released
so I calculated that total time and then
I compared it to the Gram stain time and
to the time that I reviewed the
antibiotic results
so you can see here that using the sepsi
typer kit in conjunction with the
microscan it saves about 30 hours in
comparison with a routine culture which
takes approximately 52.
52 hours and typically you know it's
about 48 hours and I do want to mention
I didn't mention this earlier that I
only looked at gram-negative organisms
because a lot of the gram-positive tend
to be contamination or coag negative
staff and there wouldn't be many
susceptibility reports listed to compare
in conclusion this is the first study to
perform a comparison of direct AST for
positive blood cultures containing
monomicrobial gram-negative organisms
with this type of instrumentation
the MBT sexy typer identified 94.6 of
isolates with 100 concordance to the
culture-based method
a main source of error was a lack of
pellet formation if you know it wasn't
abundant it was difficult to spot on the
maldi Target and also it would be
difficult to use you know the pellet for
both steps of the study
I didn't see a difference for the sepsi
typer's ability to identify
gram-positive versus gram-negative
bacteria overall I had a pretty good
success rate for both
and these are all things that I
mentioned before that the acceptance
criteria was all met for the clsi
criteria
and some other sources of error were
high pellet intake when inoculating the
prompt dilution tube it would be nice to
determine a standardized way
to make sure that we're not you know
putting too much bacteria into that
dilution tube another main problem was
interfering particles such as inclusions
of red blood cells or even the bottle
beads that were able to surpass the
needle when extracting the blood
another thing is that sample size plays
a significant role when calculating your
major and very major errors because it's
all based on dividing the total number
of isolates
um so with greater sample size these
numbers
for my um major and very major error may
have gone down
the turnaround time and comparison for
the sepsi typer and the final blood
culture reports for standard method
um was 52 hours versus about 22 hours
saving about 30 hours
and some important considerations would
be batching and microbiologist
availability 24 7. you know we would
need to determine a way how would you
know this be run in a lab because it's
not going to be where a bottle that's
flagged and this whole you know
procedure can be underway it would need
to be bashed which ultimately you know
could affect the notifications of
results how soon are we getting them to
the physician
I have said mentioned all of these
before so I'll just leave them here to
view
um but important thing is that cultures
containing polymicrobial organisms were
eliminated from the study
um because it's only FDA approved for
monomicrobial one unique thing was that
sometimes a
um
the maldi was able to detect if a bottle
you know was a polymicrobial it would
list it in the identification
section that you know it might be a
presumptive mixture and that was pretty
interesting too to look at when viewing
the report
and this was the product that I
discussed in this webinar session
um
thank you for listening and I am open to
any questions at this time